this question was submitted by text by a
member of the Institute of Electrical
and Electronics Engineers magnetics
community the question is will
carbon-based spintronic devices find
large-scale applications in the next 10
years in telling us maybe not accept
some niche application of carbon
nanotubes for connecting electronic
device but I would say that the
carbon-based material or graphene also
carbon nanotubes can play an important
call for what is called beyond CMOS
beyond the electronic with silicon seems
now that the foreign there are several
ways to heal a CMOS after 10 years from
today one of the ways molecular
electronics but molecular spintronic
also is enticing way especially with
caffeine he's seen that in material
carbon nanotubes on caffeine spin pure
spin gun can be propagated over a large
distance of the order of 50 hundred
microns and so one can imagine for exam-
types of treatment and transport and
treatment information with pure stinkin
is carbon-based materials with new tape
new types of logics a new type of
information in principle based not on
the charge but on spin currents deploy
them to the ocean of the spin
polarization of the spin currents so I I
suppose I my filling is that the cab
book makes electronics we play a whole
not even play but after 15 or 20 years
for the development of a new type of
electronics